all right uh
so thank you for inviting me to speak
today we're all in this era of speaking
into webcams and uh
it uh it's always better to be able to
see the people you're talking to but
this is the best we got these days so
regardless of anything else uh the title
of my talk is appropriate it is time for
time and in this
acronym
time t-i-m-e stands for the tumor immune
micro environment so when it comes to
cancer
immunology is what it's all about today
and it's what we're going to talk about
first a few disclosures i have been
funded by a variety of uh industrial
collaborators including bristol myers
um
leica and appirio at leica
which is a
startup company trying to do slide free
histology pfizer and agenda none of
these has actually paid me
only funding for the research projects
with the exception of i am getting an
honorarium for this presentation today
so that's my full disclosure
my objectives today are
and i've tried to keep them straight
forward for you all and not get too
complicated but
the tumor immune micro environment is
complex and so this will just be sort of
an introduction into
um what we know about the tumor immune
micro environment today and what we're
studying for the future
i have a focus which has been the focus
of my laboratory on experimental
pathology and developing
next generation mouse models of human
cancers
and
maybe a few of the new technologies that
i see
in in very common use in research today
but very rapidly
i think
translating into clinical diagnostics
and then
the focus for me scientifically is to
really attack some of the biggest
problems i study breast cancer so you're
going to hear mostly about breast cancer
today
and the three biggest problems
at least in my opinion when it comes to
breast cancer are treatment of
metastatic disease
reducing the over treatment of indolent
or
non-lethal disease
and
that's the result of sort of this failed
promise of early diagnosis where
we all believed that mammograms were
going to dramatically reduce the impact
of
breast cancer the way pap smears
dramatically
decreased the
impact of cervical cancer but it really
has not lived up to that promise
finally
i hope that some of you will take this
as a conceptual framework
for how to build teams and really do
team science to tackle questions
that are beyond the scope of of the old
way of doing research where
a single lab and maybe a single gene or
a single gene pathway
was being unraveled in a lot of detail
there's a lot of value to that and
certainly that has been
important to the way we think about
cancer um but taking a bigger picture
approach is
now necessary especially as we start to
talk about cancer immunology
so a lot of this starts from um
this important paper i mean obviously
even before this paper there was a lot
of research in the area of tumor
immunology but this one really got the
ball rolling again where
jerome gallon was able to show that
just taking small biopsies of colon
cancers you could predict the outcome of
patients based on the infiltration of
t cells those those are the cd3 cells
and whether those were
outside or infiltrating into the tumor
and
in this case also looking at cd5 45 ro
as a second marker and using those two
in ratios could separate
even the if you look at panel c at the
bottom
even the early stage disease you could
find the ones that were going to behave
very badly
versus the more common um good behavior
lesions
sort of in this very well-separated
kaplan-meier plot
um so that started us thinking and i
just want to go back a little bit and
get everybody
on the same page of where we are in
cancer today so a few years back
we realized that lung cancers could be
stratified based on egfr mutations this
was a new revolution
these egfr mutations predicted response
to
specific therapies
and i've listed two of them there
and this gave rise to the question
um about if we have better sequencing
technology
and it's become cheaper and cheaper to
sequence the cancer genome or any genome
for that matter maybe we should should
be looking at that for
sort of all patients and if we look at
cancer genomes for all patients
we can
take a different
approach to the way traditional
diagnostics
and therapy decisions were made so
traditionally we would diagnose a cancer
in a certain organ system that organ
system
cancer would go through a series of
clinical trials to figure out what the
best cancer therapies are
and
it was sort of done as an empirical or a
series of empirical experiments to
determine what were the best therapies
but here the nci established what was
called the match trial
with the idea that you could look for
specific mutations that would predict a
response to a specific therapy and you
could do that regardless of where that
tumor
originated so an egfr mutation in the
lung or an egf r mutation in any other
location
would give you a target for therapy
regardless of pre-existing known sort of
efficacy in that organ system
so this is a very simplistic kind of
approach actually as complicated as it
is because it's still one gene at a time
one gene relating to one drug at a time
um
doug hanahan and bob warr
weinberg published in about 2000 sort of
a subway map of the hallmarks to cancer
and if you think of cancer here and
egypt r is on this list i don't have a
mouse to point at it but
there's other genes on this list some of
them are druggable some of them are not
but if you think about cancer just in
terms of the subway map from the 2000
era
we think that
it makes sense to look at one gene and
one therapy regardless of whether that
cancer arose in the colon the lung or
somewhere else
uh
but even hanahan and weinberg have
recognized and so uh in about 2011 they
published an update of the hallmarks of
cancer and you can see now they've added
quite a few
additional
and very important hallmarks here so on
this list now some of the same
intrinsic cancer cell pathways
such as um sustaining proliferation so
proliferation signaling are still there
but some others are now here on this
list that
i think we should make note of so
avoiding immune destruction so immuno
evasion
tumor promoting
inflammation the micro environment is
here
and all these things
really mean that
our our old way of thinking about cancer
was too simplistic and we need to be
thinking much more about cancer in its
micro environment so here's a very
simplified
cartoon of that just introducing you to
some of the cast of characters and you
all know this
uh pretty well already but
it it sort of illustrates that
with just
an oversimplified view of two different
um
[Music]
active t cells as well as t regulatory
cells
dendritic or antigen presenting cells
macrophages the myeloid derived
suppressor cells and the nk cells
again i could go on
but that introduces this
panel now
of seven different new cells that we
need to be looking for and trying to
interrogate
their interactions with tumors
so the other big boost to
tumor
immunology has been the great success of
a new class of drugs to
specifically target
the immune checkpoint
pd1 pdl1 and this is just a cartoon
of that
illustrating the immunotherapy for
cancer and
how these drugs work it's oversimplified
of course but
some cancer cells and we found this
first in lung cancer cells
have figured out how to
fool the immune system by expressing
uh this pdl1
antibody program cell death ligand one
which interacts with the t cell and
tells the t cell hey if you're
recognizing me you're recognizing self
and you need to
just calm down and get out of here and
if you block that interaction and we've
got now drugs from four different
companies which are antibodies either
against
pd1 or pdl1 they all perform about the
same they block this interaction so the
cancer cells no longer
able to tell the t cell that there's
nothing to see here and the t cells then
will attack the cancer again
and
this can have great effect so many of
you know
a few years ago jimmy carter had
melanoma metastatic to his brain and was
treated with a anti-pd1 pdl1 therapy and
has had a durable response he's now
cancer free and he remains such
and has done very well
so if you look at the pd1 pdl1
checkpoint inhibitors
there's really still if you took all
comers of patients with metastatic
disease only about 2.2 percent
complete response
partial responses may be closer to 20
and so this has resulted in
a big deal for us in the clinic um
trying to
segregate patients based on
their tumor characteristics and
expression of
pbl1 on tumor cells or on
non-tumor cells in proximity and then as
a surrogate for tumors that have
a high
neoantigen presentation possibility
we look for total mutational burden so
tumors that have a higher total
mutational burden
make more
tumor antigens or neo antigens that
don't look like self and those patients
are also better candidates
for this pd1 pdl1 checkpoint
so in in pathology we spend a lot of
time trying to figure out how to
score the immunohistochemistry and i
won't go into all the details this is
just one of multiple guides this is for
head and neck squamous cell carcinoma
put out by deco
who makes one of the two main antibodies
used for this purpose and you can see
that
it takes a 69-page document to
educate a pathologist how to interpret
the ihc for pdl-1 so this
i think is still a work in progress
but i wanted to ask a more specific
question about how might we improve
therapy for pd-1 pdl1
therapy and so here
i
like to go back to experimental
pathology and it's hard to do these
studies in cell culture you really need
a mouse and you need a mouse which has
an intact immune system so
many of the models that we use are human
xenographs and mice or more recently the
so-called pdx mice which are
patient-derived xenographs
all of these are in mice with very
deplete
immune deficient um
context and so
my interest has been for the last 20
years to try and improve our mouse
models
that
um
that have intact immune systems and you
know ralph waldo emerson knew about this
back in the 1800s and said
his often misquoted
um
witticism about building a better
mousetrap it was actually building a
better mouse and the world will be a
path to his door and that's certainly
been the case for me my lab built
a better mouse we
built this mouse
in 2005 or published in 2005 where we
looked at two very closely related cell
lines that we derived from transgenic
mice the so-called met-1 and db-7
cells
and
these are now transplantable so you can
use them with all the convenience of
xenografts
but they're transplantable into
immune intact mice because they're syn
genetic with those immune intact
mice many of our mouse lines that we use
are our um
are congenital mouse lines and so they
are like um identical twins throughout
the entire
colony and therefore they will not
recognize as non-self tumors which were
derived from
syngenetic animals
so this
model system
has been used
by lots of investigators and i just
recently looked it up and there are
89 pubmed central articles referencing
this paper
and using this
these cell lines
and these are
we will provide these free to anyone who
asks for them so these are free to you
to use in your laboratory
if you want to study the details of a
breast cancer line that you can study
with immunology and really
drill down on
specific questions about metastasis
since these are divergent with respect
to metastasis
so a similar line a newer line that we
published more recently this was
published back
in january of last year
is an irb
mammary cancer model
this uses the so-called ndl transgenic
mouse which has a exon deletion
programmed into it so it looks very much
like
one of the common human isoforms of her2
expression which is known as the delta
16 isoform and this one uniquely
again transplantable into syngeneic mice
but this
tumor cell line expresses
pdl1 in the tumor cells and so
pdl1 is uncommonly found in breast
cancer but is sometimes found in breast
cancer and when it is
you'd have the opportunity to ask
what is the response to pdl1 therapy and
then furthermore how can we improve that
therapy again this cell line is freely
available to investigators that want to
use it and even though we just published
it back in january there are already 14
publications in the literature using
this cell line
and i invite you to inquire with me
later if you're interested in obtaining
this cell line again we're happy to
share it
so in collaboration with kathy ferrara's
lab here at uc davis and she's now moved
to stanford we
asked where and and she's an expert in
high intensity
focused ultrasound as a tumor ablative
therapy
we asked whether thermal ablation using
high intensity focused ultrasound would
release antigens and
increase the
efficacy of antigen presentation and
therefore the immune response
to
to the tumor
and we did this with and without
anti-pd1 therapy
you can see we use this timeline
in the middle where we transplanted the
cells three weeks later
we performed a simultaneous
administration
into the tumor of cpg which is the toll
agonist
it's
cng dna
recognized by toll receptor and
providing activation itself along with
anti-pd1 therapy and along with ablation
and interestingly enough to our surprise
we found that you did get a response
and so these are the green and red
curves that you see at the right
and you got that response both in the
tumor that you treated as well as
the tumor transplanted on the opposite
side of the animal that tumor on the
opposite side
is our way of measuring what's called
the abscopal response
but it can also be thought of as an
experimental version of a metastasis
and of course in patients
it's not so much the local cancer that
we have a problem treating
but the metastases
and so immunotherapy to be effective
should be effective not just against the
local therapy where we
inject
and ablate inject the cpg oligodeoxy
nucleotides
it should also be
effective at the contralateral site so
you can see we were a little
disappointed that we saw
in some ways better contralateral
response without the ablation and we
wondered about this but what um
undaunted we went on and
asked whether we could
improve this with a different schedule
and so here instead of doing everything
at the same time if you look at the
timeline you can see that we started
with the transplant we did cpg injection
along with anti-pd1 therapy
for another week and then came in with
the ablation and in this context
the combined
ablation in the contralateral site gave
us
almost complete eradication of both
sites but
now complete eradication of that
second and even third
location of
experimental metastasis and so what we
learned from this is that you really
need to prime the immune system to be
ready to recognize new antigens and then
come in with antigen release for those
antigens to be presented at which point
you get very good
immune
tumor
ablation of metastatic sites
so this has been published and i invite
you to look at the details in the
publications that are listed here this
is kathy ferrara's group just before
she moved to stanford
so what about humans can we do the same
thing in human context and so here my
collaborators at ucsf michael campbell
and lawyer laura esserman asked whether
we could
in the context of the i spy trial and
for those of you who don't know about
the i spy trial this is an adaptive
therapy trial
which has as a surrogate endpoint
the efficacy
seen
with respect to partial or complete
pathologic response in a neoadjuvant
setting so rather than having to wait
for
five or in breast cancer patients even
10 years to know whether you had an
effective therapy
we can get a readout
immediately at the time of surgery after
the neoadjuvant window and patients it
turns out who have complete pathologic
response at the time of surgery
have a very good long-term prognosis so
those two things correlate very well and
so having that very rapid ability to
evaluate new therapies
gave us the ability to begin to study
this and so we
have been looking at this in the eye spy
trial where uh adding pebruzumab to
conventional paclitaxel um
along with the doxy rubison
cyclophosphamide in a neoadjuvant
setting is giving us some ideas about
how to
add immunotherapy to our current breast
cancer and because we have biopsies you
can see at the bottom the red arrows
depict biopsies we have both before of
course for diagnosis but also on therapy
we can see the effect on the immune
system
in the context of this neoadjuvant
immunotherapy
so in order to study that we've
developed some new tools we've used
the akoya
vectra multi-spectral imaging analysis
system
in order to
try and do a better job of
characterizing the immune response both
before
during and after immunotherapy and so
this slide shows you some of the panels
we've developed you can see we want to
know where the pdl1 and pd1 are
expressed but we also want to know where
cd8 positive t cells all t cells and
macrophages are we want to know where
the fox p3 cells
are and so forth and
the ae183 is a cytokeratin marker that
marks where the epithelial cells are of
the cancer so we can
assess the proximity or interaction of
the immune cells with the cancer cells
and
those panels panel one and two were the
first that we started with but we've
expanded this to panels three and four
and 5 and i'll in a second tell you why
we went to that
in breast cancer
as i alluded to in my
introductory remarks we have
a big problem which is that we've
begun to diagnose more and more breast
cancer with the advent of screening
mammography starting in the mid 1980s
and as we
had better and better
penetrance of screening mammography we
saw more and more localized cancers and
more and more ductal carcinoma in situ
lesions
so these um
we hoped at the time
would lead to
a corresponding decrease in late stage
breast cancer so if we catch the cancers
early
we should see a dramatic decrease
in finding cancers that
present at late stage patients with
metastatic disease at the time
of presentation and unfortunately we
haven't really seen that
the epidemiologists tell us that many of
the cancers and dcis lesions that we are
detecting
and successfully treating
if we had left them alone they would
have not caused a problem and so this is
sort of the over diagnosis part
the bad side of screening mammography
and
people go to a lot of trouble to figure
out how many women do we have to treat
so that we actually find
one woman that we
have
a benefit for and
i won't get into all those numbers that
would be another talk but the answer is
that you have to
screen a lot of women you have to over
treat a lot of women or in order to
properly treat
uh even one woman and so
um
many of my colleagues say well
is you know especially in radiology we
found something you called it cancer in
the pathology lab why
is that over diagnosis
and the
person then i always have to say is
who's to blame for over diagnosis it's
the pathologist so
when we call something cancer you have
to treat it as cancer and the question
is are some of the things that we call
cancer
not really potentially lethal
and if we could do a better job of
stratifying those
and here i refer you back to slide two
with jerome gallon
if we can
maybe identify those that the immune
system is already kind of taking care of
we'd be able to reduce the
impact of our over diagnosis
um
on
um
on patients and
um
the health care system
so in the setting of
a consortium established by the national
cancer institute to really interrogate
this question this is the so-called mcl
consortium which stands for molecular
and cellular characterization of screen
detected lesions
the pathologists in the group
right away set as a priority
evaluation of the immune system in these
screen detected lesions whether they
were screen detected dcis lesions or
screen detected lesions in other
organ systems we all have the same
question which is could we predict
outcome based on specific patterns of
immune cell infiltration
so these again are the panels that we
decided to develop
the process is not trivial and maybe not
quite ready for clinical practice yet
it involves multiple steps it involves
scanning
the image and here just a tissue array
core is shown and you can see that the
scan image can then go through what's
called spectral on mixing this allows us
to reduce autofluorescence and increase
the signal to noise for each of the
channels in this case
six different channels plus a dappy
channel for nuclei
we then go through
two different machine learning based
um analyses one to do tissue
segmentation
to show the cancer cells versus the
surrounding stroma
the next one to segment individual cells
and then each individual cell can be
phenotyped with respect to its
expression for each of the markers those
phenotypes can come back to scores the
scores can go back to scoring in the two
different segmented regions the tumor
region versus the stroma region and this
becomes a very powerful but very big set
of data
this is another example going through
the same kind of segmentation with a
different type of tumor and showing a
very different kind of outcome and in
this very simplistic comparison of these
two areas i can show you
one little feature that sort of makes
sense to our thought process here and so
if we compare
the t regulatory cell density that's the
fox p3 marker
in the
top core versus the bottom core you can
see that the fox p3 is much
higher in the bottom core
and correspondingly the cd8
t cells
the killer t cells are markedly reduced
in the bottom
compared to the top so
fewer fox p3 cells
gives you more cd8 cells and more
reaction to the tumor compared to the
bottom tumor having more fox p3 cells
regulating that immune response down
regulating the cd8 immune response and
having a tumor which is much less
recognized by the immune system
oops
sorry skip the head there so t
regulatory cells of course are more
complicated they they come in different
flavors
we now know that there are t regulatory
cells that are educated in the thymus
there are also t regulatory cells
educated in the periphery and in tumor
cells
in the setting of cancer and tumor cells
we think these peripheral
educated t regulatory cells are
particularly important and that's an
area of active research in many
laboratories including my own
coming back to the eye spy trial we
asked this question about what kind of
immune landscapes do we see in breast
cancer
and
using the multi-spectral imaging and
just showing you the five markers that
were used the the six panel uh uh six
marker panel that we're using on five
cases you can see five different kinds
of patterns
in pattern five those are an example of
a tumor that itself is expressing pdl1
you can see that the tumor cells are
very
marked with the red color pdl1 this is
something that we
know happens in a lot of lung cancers
but fewer breast cancers but definitely
we think when it happens in breast
cancer it's important
but you can see
all of the different kinds of patterns
you might expect so pattern one
almost no inflammation whatsoever
pattern two inflammation but
essentially no inflammation kind of
extending into the tumor cell areas
themselves so it's sort of an immune
excluded pattern and then pattern four
at the bottom you can see
where the tumor cells are there's also a
lot of infiltration
of various
cd3 positive and cd8 positive t cells as
well as macrophages so an inflamed
phenotype
so all those
uh we we're now asking actively which of
those respond to neoadjuvant
pembroluzumab
and if we look also at
proximity of tumor cells to t cells we
can begin to unravel
which of the cells are important which
of the cells are predictive and how do
these impact this pd1 pdl1
checkpoint
with respect to outcomes
just a summary of those responses
where you see
a higher
response
you see
better
p values are the larger circles
a higher in the
non-uh complete response is blue so
that's bad higher in pathology
pathologic complete response is red so
wherever you see the large red circle
that's predictive of a response to the
pembroluzumab
this differs based on whether you are
hurt too negative
hurt to
um negative but hormone receptor
positive
or
or negative for all three markers triple
negative at the bottom but there are
similarities across all breast cancer
types
these are just the controls
so
pd1 pdl1 is one of the checkpoints but
as many of you are aware there's a whole
host of
immune synapse checkpoints that might be
at play mhc one expression has been in
the literature recently but everywhere
on this chart that you see
red letters
those are drugs that are in the pipeline
and in
development
for possible immunotherapy for cancer
and this led us to think back to them
that match trial so in the match trial
we said if every cancer has to have a
mutation some of those mutations may be
druggable we ask can we do an
immunologic version of that so if every
cancer has to evade the immune system
are there checkpoints or immune synapses
that we can target for every cancer and
so we made a short list of uh from that
previous slide of markers that we ought
to look for
we've been looking at these markers
probably each of these markers deserves
its own
symposium with multiple talks but i
won't go into that i'll just point out
that
we can mark for each of these markers
here's a dual mark with the t cells
along with the aux 40 marker
here's the lag three marker
here's jitter um
again
mark's
importance cell subsets here's vista or
v7h5
along with
cd3
uh here's
uh vista by itself without the cd3 cell
so you can see that there's actually a
range of expression from low expressors
to high expressors of vista
here's 7h4 much less common but
definitely
scattered cells which are b7 h4 positive
here
here's b7h3
expressed we think more on
antigen presenting and dendritic cells
interestingly here's tim3 tim3 you kind
of have to dial up the signal to see the
brightest cells and we think it's
probably the brightest cells that are
the most important so all of these
immune synapse pathways are part of the
future i think of immunotherapy and
biomarkers for immunotherapy
all right so lastly i want to tackle
sort of this pre-cancer problem in
breast cancer
the pre-cancer problem
i broke down into four categories
the
over diagnosis
problem i showed you is largely due to
over diagnosis of ductal carcinoma in
situ and so we really need to do a
better job of telling which ductal
carcinoma in situ
is and is not going to progress
i also think that some of the highest
risk invasive cancers really don't even
have that
detectable intraductal component
dcis is a heterogeneous array of
diseases but they all have this
increased risk of invasive cancer
and
my colleague laura esserman will tell
you that
the the evidence does not support our
current standard of care our current
standard of care is surgical therapy
often followed by radiation therapy to
completely eradicate the part of the
ductal tree that harbors this
intraductal neoplasm
and i
really like this picture this is a
picture of
dcis kind of at its worst it's in action
you can see that it's not a simple
question
to know
how the micro invasion here at the
bottom
left at sort of between seven and nine
o'clock is occurring you can see that
there's necrosis in the center of this
dcis and you can see inflammatory cells
scattered around the periphery what are
those inflammatory cells doing
are they now permitting or are they
suppressing the invasion of dcif
and so
more and more we're looking at the
immune system as a way to predict risk
and response and if we begin to look at
the inflammatory response around dcis
you can see that we definitively have
different patterns in different dcis
cases so the cases are listed at the top
conventional markers like her2
positivity and er positivity
are given at the uh
at the top bars there with her2 being
that bright blue her2 negative being
light blue you can see her2 expression
is very common we're going to come back
to that very common in dcis much more
common in dcis than it is in invasive
cancer er positivity very common also in
dcis but if we look at these
now her2 positive over at the left edge
and we look at the inflammatory response
these have some of the highest levels
of cd8 infiltration
but even these are broken down into
subgroups
of three or four cases each which have
um
stromal pdl1 cd868 cells that express
pdl1 at the far left versus macrophages
for cd68 that don't express pdl1 um in
that box um
two steps to the right and then
in the in between them um
high cd8 cells but
very few macrophages
there are also this group at the far
right
that have very little inflammation
almost no t cells and no macrophages
infiltrating in or around
in the stroma
the dcis cases at the far
far right there
in the middle here's another group
that's somewhat interesting with very
little immune response but the dcis
cells themselves express pdl1 and so
at the right
no inflammation but it's not we don't
think because of pdl1 but in the middle
here's a subgroup that seems to have
pdl1 expression
mitigating the immune response to the
dcis
right next to that here's cd68 cells
this time the macrophages are the ones
expressing the pdl one so all these
different categories are important we
think proximity of t regs to other t
cells is also important and we're
working on that so very quickly these
proximity analyses can be added you know
what i just showed you was just the very
top of this picture the very top of this
heat map but the heat map can be grown
out
to do all this proximity analysis and
interrogation of which different
categories we have for dcis lesions
lastly i want to introduce you to a
couple of concepts with regard to
pre-cancer the pre-cancer atlas project
is funded by
the moonshot initiative at the nci
here we're looking across different
tumor types and asking whether we can
characterize those pre-cancers with
respect to risk
some of the sub-aims of the pre-cancer
project involve the pre-cancer tumor
immune environment 4.2 that i was just
talking about
as well as
um just trying to get an archive of the
histology and phenotypes
that we
interrogate in this
cohort and so just some of the very
preliminary data
you might ask about ductal carcinoma in
situ and the clonal evolution of lesions
across space
and we've been studying that
in addition to gene expression analysis
so just like
um we can interrogate the immune cells
in the histology we can also interrogate
the immune cells as
as evidenced by the gene expression from
the bulk um rna expression from an area
of tumor
so lastly um how do we study this back
in experimental model systems so my lab
has worked with the so-called minnow
model that we developed
which stands for mammary
intra-epithelial neoplasia outgrowth
again these are transplant model systems
of complex tissues in an immune intact
animal and we found that you could have
a progression
consistently from pre-cancer to invasive
cancer in this model system
some of these are metastatic and some
are not they segregate and it gives you
a unique opportunity to study those
pre-cancerous lesions that are the most
important versus those that are the most
innocuous
in another model system
the
stat one knockout mouse which was made
as a way to
reduce natural killer t cell function
there's a nice um
cell article
from the schreiber lab that points out
that
these stat 1 knockout mice
are susceptible to obligate
intracellular pathogens like listeria
challenge but it turned out these
mice also developed mammary tumors and
they developed a unique pattern of
mammary tumor that we
think is very analogous to age-related
er positive breast cancer
which is
the most common type of breast cancer
and also
despite an overall good prognosis in the
category still the number one
cause of breast cancer death and we
asked whether
this was because of the natural killer
t-cell defect associated with a
difference in inflammation
whereby
you might hypothesize that
women as they age have reduced
ability to be
effective at
immunosurveillance or immunosuppression
of
these
age-related er positive breast cancers
and i invite you to look at this paper
in detail very interestingly it showed
that the tumor cells express
chemoattractants for macrophages but
also express
chemo
repellents for macrophages and this
resulted in macrophages that come close
to the cancer but then are not able to
attack the cancer or prevent its spread
because of the chemo repellent effects
and those segregate into extracellular
vesicle fractions and soluble fractions
which are these dot plots that are very
small down at the bottom in panels g h
and i
but i invite you to look at the camp at
the at the paper for more details
[Music]
so a few clues about
how dcis might progressing progress come
from her too i think her2 expression
it turns out in
dcis is seen
in at least
35 percent in this case compared to
invasive carcinoma at only 12 percent so
that i think provides a clue that
her2 might be recognized by the immune
system and might be one of the ways
that
the immune system prevents
dcis at least her to expressing dcis
from invading and so we asked a simple
question
about
how
might a dcis evade the immune system and
we think the answer is at least
partially related to
mis-expression of isoforms of her2 and
there are different isoforms this is
sort of less well-known but is known in
the literature that this pattern up at
the very top
where you show that there's only
detection by the green antibody the
intracellular domain of her2 but there's
complete loss of the extracellular
domain of her2 and we hypothesized that
loss of the extracellular domain of her2
while it still gives you her2 signaling
and oncogenic potential
reduces the ability of the immune system
to recognize
that her2 and additional patterns were
seen you do see some full length
um apparent full length but you also see
partial losses that can be subclonal and
you can see gradients of loss of the
extracellular domain of her2 in that
pattern 4 at the bottom
and
that we hypothesize
may be due to post-translational
cleavage events in her2 that are very
common so going back to the mouse my
colleague josh schneider at duke was
able to model this in what's called the
rainbow mouse and this is unpublished
data but we hope it will be published
soon and you'll be able to reference the
full paper
but we were able to engineer this mouse
to express the different isoforms in the
same mouse and then ask about the
outcomes of those mice and very
interestingly
the p95 loss of extracellular domain
does show a very different kind of
immune pattern immune reaction and shows
much more invasiveness
if you do single cell rna sequence
analysis of those epithelial cells and
fibroblasts you can see that
there's a much greater
impact of the immune system and the
fibroblast in those
extracellular domain laws and even at
the very earliest stages these p95
lesions are the most invasive and show
the least
containment by the stroma and the immune
system so overall this gives us some
clues and i'm just going to wrap up here
because i'm getting near the end of my
time that we may be able to reclassify
dcis in part based on the immune
recognition of dcis we may furthermore
be able to treat dcis
with an immunotherapy that would
encourage the immune system to continue
or increase the immunosurveillance to
prevent that
emergence of an invasive lesion at the
stage of dcis
and
[Music]
that's sort of the goal i hope that we
get there i think you're going to see
these tools
that we're using in research implemented
in the clinic
in very short order um in part maybe to
just begin to interrogate
response or prediction of response to
specific immunotherapies and drugging
the immune synapse but also maybe to
reclassify and rediagnose change our
classification schemes for invasive
cancers as well as in situ lesions into
those that are
immune evasive versus immune
non-invasive and kept in check already
by the immune system and
and this i think will be an important
part of the future of pathology
diagnostic
um i hope that i've convinced you that
teamwork is important here i talked
about many of my collaborators all of
them with unique skills and
subsets of expertise
we may all be blind men but we're all
um
we're blind men and women but we're
also very good at working together and
communicating and so
at the end of the day hopefully we can
get
a better picture of the elephant
the pathologist has to be involved in
many of the steps along the way and i
hope i've convinced you of that that
it's one of the rules of pathologists to
put the
big picture together with the gene
expression the cytokines and immunology
the flow cytometry
and put that in the context of what's
going on
where the rubber meets the road at the
point where the immune cells are
interacting at the
the invasive front of the tumor and and
how effective or non-effective are those
so in summary
the major problems
in cancer including better treatment of
aggressive and metastatic disease
reducing over diagnosis and
overtreatment disease and finding
real pre-cancers very early these
nascent lethal pre-cancers that are
defined at least in part by
a very early
evidence of immune escape as well as
immune
stromal interaction
are possible using some of these new
technologies for research and
translation i showed you a lot of
multiplex immunohistochemistry
sort of a blend of flow cytometry and
conventional histology i showed you some
single cell rna sequence data and that's
becoming more and more important
important in research and giving us more
targets
to
handle these but
as you saw this becomes a very big
picture big data problem which requires
new
computing and informatics tools to
handle both of those and it takes a team
of the blind scientists and a chance to
put them together to make meaningful
progress so with that
i'll acknowledge all of my collaborators
and co-investigators
as well as the funders and the industry
partners that have made all this
possible
and i'm happy to take
any questions